is it a staggering responsive
responsibility that the the head of a
bank could literally could literally
crash our economy
astonishing that's like if you have I
mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in the
guaranteed a guaranteed way to be saved
by again by no matter no matter if I
have my how
you know I'll give you an example uh the
Republicans want to give a work
requirement for snap you know for a a a
a hungry family has to to have these
this kind of penalties are these some
kinds of word working uh required
shouldn't you have a working requirement
after we sell your bank with billions of
your bank
because they seem to be more preoccupied
uh when then snap uh and requirements
for works for hungry